now that xiang chi has stepped up to
take his place in the marvel cinematic
universe there's no better time to get
the lowdown on the villains and rogues
he's faced over the years from mighty
crime lords to international assassins
these are shang chi's biggest foes
ever since his debut in 1973's special
marvel edition number 15 chongqi's one
true archenemy has always been his evil
scheming father in the 70s the so-called
kung fu craze reached america's shores
so marvel decided to purchase the comic
book rights to sax romer's fuumon chew
novels and created chongqi as his
previously unknown son fu manchu was the
racist xenophobic personification of
yellow peril the western fear that asian
immigrants would eventually wipe out
white culture around the world marvel
used the loss of the rights to romer's
creations as an opportunity to establish
a new backstory for chongqi's father one
that attempted to distance the villain
from his racist roots resurrected and
renamed zhang zhu in 2010's secret
avengers number eight the master of kung
fu's father was now an immortal wizard
who sought to conquer the world using
his vast criminal cult the five weapons
society the original zoo remained shang
chi's biggest enemy until his first
death in master of kung fu number 118
though the character would make several
brief returns in the years that followed
after shang qi rebelled against his
father zhang zhu sent his adopted son
the midnight son to bring him back one
way or another the adoptive brothers
clashed in special marvel edition number
16 fighting a fierce battle that
ultimately ended in tragedy midnight
sun's real name was monae and he was the
only survivor of a british assault on
his village wishing to cultivate the
hate within him zhang zhu adopted the
boy and raised him alongside shang chi
though the two men loved each other
deeply midnight's son was more loyal to
his father than he was to shang chi and
their duel only ended when monae died
after falling off a construction crane
though he was killed in his first
appearance minaj would prove to be the
first of many siblings who would become
shan chi's enemy
originally one of saks roamer's
problematic fu manchu characters follow
c's name was changed to zhang bao once
marvel lost to the rights the daughter
of zhang zhu bao yu was shang chi's half
sister and although the two sought to
defeat their father they wanted to do so
for completely different reasons while
chongqi wanted to bring an end to zoo's
criminal empire and the destruction it
caused around the globe bau wished to
supplant their father and claim his
empire for herself value debuted in
1975's master of kung fu number 26 in
which she butted heads with shang chi
for the first time for a period she also
managed to gain control of mi6 causing
chongqi and his many spy allies to leave
the agency and create an independent spy
agency called freelance restorations
introduced in 1975's giant size master
of kung fu number four the outsider
known only as tiger claw approached
zhang zhu and demanded that the villain
make him a lodge master one of the top
ranking members of the celestial order
of the siphon his private society of
assassins angered by the strangers in
pertinence zhu sent three siphon lodge
masters to kill him but tigerclaw killed
them instead convinced that he might
have finally found a match for chongqi
zoo allowed tigerclaw to replace the men
he had killed and become a lodgemaster
himself zeus hopes would soon be dashed
however confident in large part due to
his new position the lodge master
challenged the son of zhongzu to a duel
though the fight was fierce tiger claw
was decisively defeated by the
undisputed master of kung fu
the first villain known as razer fist
was simply an enhanced bodyguard named
william young who worked for a crime
lord named carlton velcro when chongqi
and this first razor fist finally met in
the field of battle velcro's guards
accidentally shot and killed him while
trying to hit xiang chi years later
velcro decided to create two new racer
fists when two of his men brothers
william and douglas scott each lost a
hand in a car accident unfortunately
william ultimately died in the same
manner as his namesake when velcro
accidentally shot and killed him this
left douglas scott as the sole remaining
razor fist douglas reappeared several
times over the years and has even come
to blows with a number of other marvel
superheroes
knowing he would never be able to
dismantle his father's vast empire on
his own sean chi soon began working with
mi6
bond
james bond one of these agents was a man
named simon brettner after spending
years working as a secret agent for mi6
brettner began developing a dual
personality named mordillo who quickly
became one of the world's most dangerous
assassins when chongqi inadvertently
kept mordillo from finishing a contract
he vowed revenge on the kung fu master
hatching a plot against his very own
teammates brettner's fellow agent laiko
wu eventually discovered his treachery
and helped mi6 track bretner to his
secret island hideout where the villain
equipped his most dangerous weapon the
death head a steel gauntlet that could
shoot fire and poison darts from its
fingertips death hand proved himself a
worthy opponent for chongqi but the
villain was ultimately incinerated when
he accidentally leapt directly into the
path of a laser weapon
introduced in master of kung fu number
42 in 1976 lancaster sneed adopted the
name shockwave after he used metal
plates to rebuild himself in the wake of
a horrific injury in the process he
vowed revenge on those he believed were
responsible for his injuries mi6
shockwave attacked mi6 and used his
specialized armor to give even seongchi
a run for his money the armor granted
sneed an incredible amount of protection
gave him a slight boost in speed
strength and agility and equipped him
with jet powered flight laser cannons
and shock wave emitters chongqi later
discovered that snead was in fact the
nephew of his mi6 allies sir dennis
nalen smith before defeating him for
good
zhang zhu's criminal empire wasn't built
in a day in fact his grand celestial
orders were developed over the course of
centuries thanks to the long life he
received by taking the elixir of life
also known as the elixir vitae according
to 2010 shield number four the elixir
was invented by none other than sir
isaac newton decades before that issue
was released however the elixir of life
was believed to have been developed by
zhang zhu's distant ancestor chaka khan
introduced in master of kung fu number
46 zheng zhu recovered khan's skeleton
from its tomb and used his unique mix of
mystic and scientific knowledge to
return his soul to his undead body
shakir khan was said to be the greatest
warrior who ever lived and zhu was
certain this would finally bring about
the end of his son chongqi after one of
the most harrowing battles of his entire
career chongqi emerged victorious
defeating his ancestor and foiling his
father's plans once again
gregory sobchenko was introduced in
1982's master of kung fu number 110
thanks to his father's position as a
high-ranking member of the kgb gregory
was chosen to join a rare exchange
program between china and russia during
which two of the most skilled chinese
martial artists would trade places with
one russian for a period of 15 years
ghost maker came into conflict with
chongqi and mi6 during the russian
agent's attempted assassination of queen
elizabeth ii though usually the assured
victor in any fight chongqi was shocked
to discover that he couldn't beat the
ghost maker in combat and was narrowly
defeated a number of times eventually
ghost maker made a mistake however and
accidentally doused himself in the acid
he had meant to use on the queen a good
villain rarely stays down however and
grigri was eventually resurrected by the
hand in 1994's daredevil annual number
10. with daredevil and chongqi's help
elektra defeats the assassin by stabbing
him in the head killing him once more
one of the most visually striking
villains in the trailer for shang chi
and the legend of the ten rings death
dealer appeared in only a handful of
comic book issues in 1982 while zhang
bao yu was director of mi6 a man named
lee ching lin infiltrated the agency's
ranks to serve as a double agent for
zheng zhu fearing chingling's brutality
value hired sir dennis naland smith and
her brother xiangchi to take out the
dangerous assassin shanxi easily bested
the double agent and forced ching lin to
flee back to zhang zhu who outfitted him
with new weapons and named him the death
dealer after meeting in battle on a
number of occasions death dealer and
chongqi fought one last time at jiang
zhu's castle still just as outmatched as
before death dealer was killed by
chongqi and master of kung fu number 118
when the hero hit the villain with a lit
brazier causing his costume to catch
fire
the main villain of the shanxi master of
kung fu mini-series moving shadow was
yet another son of zhongzu who sought to
defeat chongqi and replace him at their
father's side introduced in the series
first issue in 2002 moving shadow would
prove to be a challenging foe for his
heroic brother like chongqi moving
shadow was trained in the ways of
martial arts from birth but unlike the
master of kung fu he completely embraced
his father's evil ways and vowed to
serve him with absolute loyalty
ultimately shanxi once again proved
himself to be the better fighter and
defeated his half-brother in combat
utterly beaten and left in disgrace
moving shadow returned to zhengzhu but
the cold-blooded villain killed his son
for his failure
secret avengers number one introduced a
new threat to the marvel universe the
shadow council an organization formed by
confederate soldiers from the american
civil war who discovered a rift in time
and space after steve rogers returned
from his apparent death in 2010's
captain america reborn he decided to
form a new covert ops team of avengers
to investigate and defeat this new evil
when the shadow council tries to
resurrect zhang zhu steve rogers
approaches chongqi and asks for his help
rogers team of secret avengers includes
sharon carter the beast ant-man the
black widow valkyrie moon knight and war
machine and together they fight the
shadow council and a half dead zhang zhu
they eventually managed to disrupt the
ritual that would have fully resurrected
sean chi's villainous father sending him
right back to hell
though white dragon originally debuted
in 1978's amazing spider-man number 184
he wouldn't battle chongqi until 2014's
deadly hands of kung fu number two and
three when an old enemy named chao sima
approached the master of kung fu and
asked for his help in avenging the death
of his true love though he initially
distrusted the former villain chongqi
agreed to help him and the duel
infiltrated the white dragon's
headquarters where they discovered a
secret ritual led by none other than a
resurrected midnight sun
what a twist
as midnight's sun's willing servant the
white dragon held off chongqing and
chaosima until he killed skull crusher
in order to complete the ritual chaosima
had gotten the upper hand however and
made sure that the ceremony didn't grant
midnight's sun power but instead
resurrected his beloved lako who cast
sun into the underworld
introduced in 2020 xiangchi number one
one of the master of kung fu's most
recent villains is yet another secret
sibling zhong shiwa is shan chi's
younger sister and the two were raised
together until zoo separated them for
trespassing in a forbidden room zoo
branded the girl's forehead and lied to
her brother implying that she had been
executed in order to teach him a lesson
in reality xi wang was sent to russia to
join the five weapons society's house of
the deadly hammer where she finished her
training and adopted the title of
sisterhammer when zheng zhu died once
again the five weapons society was left
without a leader and sisterhammer was
determined to take her father's place
and lead the organization as she saw fit
naming herself the new supreme commander
chihuahua tried to have chongqi killed
but only succeeded in revealing to
shanghi that she is still alive the
master of kung fu attempted to convince
his long-lost sister to forsake their
father and leave his evil ways behind
but when she refused chongqi defeated
her in combat and took control of the
five weapons society himself vowing to
turn it into a force for good
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel comics are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one